This is Thaddeus Matthews.
I'm the guy that you're talking
about all around the country
as the "cussing pastor."
Yes, I curse!
Hell, Jesus probably cursed!
Jesus be sittin' up in Heaven
lookin' at
you ignorant-ass Negroes
and saying, "Damn,
I made that fool?"
You got to be careful,
ladies, who you [bleep].
You [bleep] some of
anything and everybody.
I cuss! Everybody cuss!
Do you kiss your flock
with that mouth?
That guy spittin' the holy shit
is Thaddeus, the Cussin' Pastor.
And the only thing he has
in common with Billy Graham
is that they're both
a little ashy.
Dropping F-bombs
in the name of religion
is better than dropping actual
bombs because of religion.
Woke joke.
As long he's not giving
reach-arounds to altar boys,
I don't give a shit
what he says.
Hosanna!
Cuss words
are a gift from God.
Without them,
all rappers would be Will Smith.
Bill Cosby famously
refused to use profanity,
but he'll be cursing up a storm
in prison
when he's forced to take
his cellmate's pudding pop
and put it in...
[as Bill Cosby] "You see! Rudy!"
I heard George Carlin
used to do a bit
about the seven dirty words
you can't say on television.
Let's see how it holds up.
Shit, piss, [bleep], [bleep],
[bleep]sucker, mother[bleep],
and tits.
Turns out it's now four.
That's progress!
[ Laughter ]
I wouldn't mind adding "squirt"
to the list.
That word is gross.
Squirt.
Thaddeus has a clean soul
attached to a filthy mouth.
But you got to preach blue
to put asses in the pew.
That's why I flew
the Cussin' Pastor to Hollywood,
where everyone's Jewish,
for this week's
CeWEBrity Profile.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
What the [bleep]
is all this?
Pastor Matthews.
You're the first to arrive.
Have a seat.
Thanks for speaking
at my super-secret
celebrity prayer group.
Thanks to the godless liberals
who run Hollywood,
the most hated group here isn't
women or people of color...
it's Christians.
Well, I don't consider myself
a Christian.
I call myself
a spiritualist,
and I think that everyone,
even if it's these characters
in Hollywood,
should be able to
address themselves
to the god of their choice.
Unless it's
the Church of Scientology.
Then damn them to hell,
I say.
Hell, they been
[bleep] up all the time.
Is it the "Cursing Pastor,"
or the "Cussing Pastor"?
It's the Cussing Pastor.
There's a difference.
Okay.
In cussing, I use words
that you may think are not
the proper words, or --
I'm fine with all of them,
for the record.
Okay.
If I tell you, "Take yo' ass
to Hell, you're going to Hell,
you ain't no damn good,"
you know, "yous a mother[bleep]
low life," that's cursing.
That was like three examples
there, that was a lot.
But Jesus was a cusser.
You think Jesus cussed
when they were hammering
the nails into his hands?
If somebody was putting nails
in your hands,
you'd say a little shit too,
wouldn't you?
I definitely would.
Is your message tailored
to more the black community,
or are you open to all?
The truth
is not tailor-made,
the truth is just the truth,
no matter who you are.
Okay.
Jesus was not a white man.
I know that blonde-haired,
blue-eyed guy that --
Beautiful blonde hair,
blue eyes. Nice abs.
You know, his name
is Cesare Borgia.
Jesus's name
was Cesare Borgia?
He was a homosexual.
Jesus was a homosexual?!
That one y'all got
on the wall.
Oh, the one that we have
on the walls is a homosexual.
He looks like a homosexual.
Are you a Steelers fan?
Yes, I am.
What do you think...
was that a catch?
We should've went
to the Super Bowl.
I know.
I had all my money
on the Super Bowl,
and I thought the Steelers
were a sure thing.
Okay, but I thought the Bible
was against gambling.
I think that one of the things
the church has done,
you're alienating
young folk,
because you've got
all of these doctrines
and these misconceptions
of what Jesus said
and, hell,
you wasn't there.
It's about being real,
it's about the truth,
and I don't give a damn
what none of you bitches said --
and none of you hoe-ass [bleep],
either.
You were put in
Facebook prison.
I just got out of
Facebook jail Friday.
I went back in
while I was here.
Statistically, most people
that get out of Facebook jail
end up
back in Facebook jail.
Church is boring.
Not mine.
That's what I'm sayin'!
You've made something that a lot
of young people find boring
very entertaining.
And I don't get paid
at my church. I get no salary.
You don't pass
the collection?
We pass the basket,
of course...
Okay.
...because church
is a business.
But you don't have to
pay taxes.
Praise the lord!
[ Laughs ]
What about premarital sex?
What about it?
Is it okay?
I wouldn't have a woman
that I ain't
tried it out with.
Uh-huh.
Would you?
No. No.
I mean,
you've tried out women.
I might need to try it out
for a year, year and a half.
Yeah!
Yeah, you at least all know
what you're riding in.
'Cause I like a lot of
the more freaky things.
Okay.
So you might not be
no freak.
See, it's a turn on to me
to watch a woman take a dildo
and do that thing to her...
get that thing
that twirls all around.
Hell, when you get 60 years old,
damn, it's less work for you.
Oh, no, no, I'm -- listen,
I'm all for taking a
shortcut wherever I can.
[ Laughs ]
I didn't mean to imply
that I don't need help.
Let me tell you something.
Some of the biggest freaks I've
ever found is in the church.
You get one of them,
"I ain't never did this
before in my life,"
then she blows you
like you're a trombone.
I have a masseuse,
if you need it.
Thanks, Pete.
How do you justify swearing
when Ephesians 4:29 says,
"Do not let any unwholesome talk
come out of your mouths
but only what is helpful
for building others up"?
What's unwholesome to you, does
it have to be unwholesome to me?
Yes.
Why?
Because all men
are created equal.
No, we're not.
Okay.
I don't think
that the problem is in...
That's good, that's good.
Do you want a massage?
No. That's all right.
You sure?
He got a sister?
You got to have a man rub you,
'cause it's stronger.
It feels way better.
I know some strong women
that can do it good.
Mm...
You don't mind
your male pastor
taking [bleep] up the ass
and [bleep] dick.
You don't mind when he lays his
hands on you on Sunday morning
his hands have been on
some man's sweaty balls.
Is it really possible
to pray the gay away?
If you like a little [bleep]
in your ass, fine.
Hold on, not all gay people
have anal sex.
They don't?
No!
What do they do?
Uh, blowjobs.
That's all?
Hand-- Yeah.
Just like a lot of straight men
like anal sex.
Nngh.
Don't look at me
like that.
No, there's some freak
in you.
Some straight men like a finger
in their butt from their lady.
Your butthole doesn't
know the difference between
a big finger
and a small dick.
I bet it does.
No, it doesn't.
What's your favorite
cuss word?
Mother[bleep].
See, mother[bleep]
is so descriptive.
You can be
a white mother[bleep],
a black mother[bleep]...
I don't ever put a color
in front of mother[bleep].
...a rich mother[bleep]...
I like that.
...an old mother[bleep],
ugly mother[bleep].
A dusty mother[bleep].
Yeah!
A bad mother[bleep].
Raunchy mother[bleep].
Sweaty mother[bleep].
Yes.
Preppy mother[bleep] [bleep]
Alabama mother[bleep]!
Yes! Yes!
So many mother[bleep].
Any Christian worth his salt
watches Fox News,
so I trust you've seen ads
for the Wonder Bible.
No.
It's this plastic
little radio,
and then it just reads you
some out-of-context scripture
with no real message.
The only thing I "wonder" is how
they haven't gone bankrupt.
But I say we take
that 1978 technology
and create a product
that even nonbelievers
would find cool as shit.
I could create
one of those.
Announcer:
Throw away your Wonder Bible.
It's The Boom Bible
by Thaddeus.
The Good Book
just got better.
Paper Bibles are so flimsy
and old-fashioned.
No thanks!
With The Boom Bible,
the sacred scriptures
are available
at the touch of a button.
The King Kendrick version
of the scriptures, that is.
Written and read by
the Cussing Pastor himself,
Thaddeus Matthews.
A raw, street-smart remix
of the holy word.
Take God's ghetto blaster
with you everywhere you go.
You've got to reach the kids
to teach the kids.
Take it on faith,
there's nothing cooler.
When you don't know
what to say,
let God and Thaddeus
speak for you.
The Boom Bible by Thaddeus.
Keep your favorite filthy pastor
right at your fingertips.
And I swear to God,
act now and we'll include
close to a pound and a half
of skirt steak,
and this coffee mug
that says "Boss Bitch."
Call today.
[ Cheers and applause ]
So much more talk
about dildos
than I was expecting
from a pastor.